bonjour c'est monsieur dream et
aujourd'hui je vais quoi quoi mon
t-shirt et très bien mon t-shirt qui
pique un peu les yeux mais le coup
ouais rien à voir mais aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler de facebook
monsieur dream à facebook ce magnifique
service ou le but du jeu est d'avoir le
plus d'amis possible ainsi à silva 6 g
4894 amis sur facebook
voilà j'essaie donc luke skywalker et
les quatre tortues ninja il n'existe pas
je le truc qui ouvre sur facebook c'est
qu'on est tous bowie si vous regardez
photos des profils des gens les gens
sont tous beaux moi j'ai une copine qui
est moche elle est vraiment pas belle
aya rien à sa place pas bon elle a aussi
à prendre une photo d'elle pour son
profil on voit que son oeil est à un
bout de cinq jours comme ça et bien les
belles mais je pense que c'est pas la
seule et isa même technique et sur les
photos de profil est un phénomène qui
est très intéressant c'est les photos en
noir et blanc un coup comme si les gens
achetaient encore des appareils photos
en noir et blanc en 2009 c'est un peu
comme si moi je me filmer en noir et
blanc 1 1 ce n'est pas un petit peu con
quand même un tout petit peu sur
facebook et donc les photos de profil et
les photos où on a tagué dessus alors là
c'est pas toi qui a pris la photo tu as
rien demandé t'es pas du tout en noir et
blanc et pour le coup tu es vraiment pas
beau souvent en cédant des soir est un
vomi sur quelqu'un calcat a vomi dessus
c'est bizarre et c'est très fort parce
que parfois même très souvent on n'a pas
du tout envie d'être tagué sur ces
photos alors monsieur dream je voulais
vous voir parce que vous êtes en congé
maladie pourtant j'ai vu que vous êtes
tagué sur des photos sur facebook où
vous êtes en boîte de nuit
j'attends des expressions ça ça c'est
parce qu'en fait je gilles maladie très
rare voilà en fait je suis malade que
les heures impaires facebook c'est aussi
très pratique pour retrouver des vieux
potes perdu de vue à six mois j'ai
retrouvé des tes potes mais parfois
c'est des gens ça fait un petit peu trop
longtemps que ça va
même salut dream tu te souviens de mon
ainsi oui
ah oui tu étais toujours collé à ta
grande soeur à la récré eux j'ai pas de
soeur à merde
facebook a littéralement dénaturer les
anniversaires maintenant tout le monde
s'en fout 1 le jour de mon anniversaire
par un coup de fil par sms j'ai eu des
messages sur mon vol le seul cadeau que
j'ai eue c'était ma mère qui m'a offert
une image un dollar sur facebook
merci maman mais ça l'est et enfin la
crème des crèmes sur facebook les
groupes
bien entendu si vous regardez bien les
gens ne s'inscrive que sur des groupes
un petit peu fou fou n'est pas trop hein
c'est genre de groupe à
quand je me réveille j'ai les cheveux en
pétard ou alors parfois je mets mon
t-shirt à l'envers
par contre tu ne verras personne dans le
groupe g des hémorroïdes ou alors je ne
paye pas les impôts ce qu'il faudrait
c'est faire comme pour les photos en
fait pouvoir tailler les gens sur des
groupes par exemple le tag charles
endives dans le groupe des gens qui se
grattent les coûts et à s'y passe ici je
t'ai vu c'est pour toutes ces raisons
que j'ai sur facebook oui en même temps
c'est la seule façon qu'à ma mère
d'avoir des nouvelles
monsieur dream